[Music]
I would love to carry curious how did
you get involved with interviewing
people I start interviewing people when
my mom got like more contact so that's
so she told so she
and how old are you okay and what advice
do you have for beginning filmmakers
[Music]
to watch movies first and try to see
what they what's what good stuff is in
movies like oh like they can analyze the
movies mark and they can use that
structure that's great what about people
that just want to be in the business
actors or people that maybe want to do
red carpet interviews like you do what
advice do you have for them how do you
overcome nervousness that's something
that I struggle with sometimes
and then once I've noticed play in the
school and that is called Star Search
everybody wanted to be the main
character which was the Sun but nobody
asked that they were shiny but then I
spoke up and I said I wanted to be it
then the teacher gave me the room oh
that's nice so just promoting yourself
and and being your own supporter oh
that's good okay mom unless she promotes
me because I don't have time for that
Oh aha you're busy what advice do you
have for people maybe they live in
another state maybe they live in the
Midwest and they want to come to Los
Angeles and they wanted to get involved
in the movies whether it's behind the
scenes or in front of the camera like
you do what advice do you have
[Music]
we're going to pack their bags and come
out here what would you what would you
say to them how would they how should
they make that that move let's make
Chicago to LA a lot of oil okay that's
good yeah it definitely is that's good
advice right there
and lastly Perry before we go tell us
about some of the interviews that you've
done this whole entire week is full of
interviews so like so
by channel six people and Friday I was
into beautiful by Mike castle chief work
there's lots of interviews and do you
have any message for your fans
what would your message on it's a happy
oh I'm sure you have a lot of fans to go
onto my website
and then they can check out stuff you
see this this is the San Diego indie
fest so that they can just you think
there's some free passes in here on my
website well we've been speaking with
mr. Barry Chen at the 6th annual San
Diego indie fest
you